Writing online will change your life,
but probably not in the way that you
think. Sure, there are the things that
everyone talks about, like growing an
audience or increasing your income,
attracting opportunities, or building
your personal brand. And yes, those are
real benefits, but they're the
consequences of writing online. They're
what happens after your writing works.
But what nobody talks about is what the
writing does to you, whether or not
anyone actually reads it. Because
writing nonfiction, from micro essays to
tweets, from newsletters to books, is
not just a way to share what you think.
It's how you figure out what you think
in the first place. And that's why as an
English professor, I'm always stressing
that learning to write might be the
single most practical skill that you can
develop. So in this video, I'm going to
break down a step-by-step process for
how to write well, and no, we're not
going to talk about grammar. Why writing
makes you powerful and by that, I don't
mean something empty and clickbaity. I'm
talking about real power, which is the
ability to wield influence and affect
change in the world, and how to find
your writer's voice in a way that can't
be replaced by AI. All right, so if you
want to write well, then you know what,
I'm going to take out that word write
well, and I'm going to say write
valuably. Because in the world of
nonfiction, readers are not interested
in your grammar, they're not interested
in your word choice. They are trading
you their attention for value. So let's
get rid of the question of how to write
well and think about how to write
valuably. And if you're writing
valuably, it means you're answering
questions or solving problems. And in
order to do that, you need to use
writing as your thinking. But a lot of
writers don't get this. They've been
trained by schoolmarms to do their
thinking first and then write it up. And
that works well in school, but it does
not work on planet nonfiction because in
order to answer questions and solve real
problems, then you need to be generating
new knowledge. But a lot of these
school-bred writers will approach their
writing in reverse. So they basically
start with their thesis. Thesis is what
we call it in school, but you start with
your conclusion, you start with your
idea, and then you go looking for
evidence, anecdotes, metaphors, whatever
that the stuffing of that idea in order
to support it. And if you approach your
writing this way, then your evidence
becomes kind of like a decoration. It's
like you've already got your idea, and
now you're trying to think about how to
communicate this idea, and so you go
looking for evidence like a quote or or
a story or whatever kind of stuff you're
using in order to support it. But if
you're doing that, then you are not
writing valuably. You're not generating
new knowledge, you're not solving real
problems, and you're not answering
questions that anyone actually has. So
this problem usually comes up whenever
writers think about their texts as being
about a topic. So you pick a topic like
a noun, and you start writing about it.
And if you write that way, then
everything becomes evidence for your
idea. You don't have any way to direct
your writing and your thinking. So
instead of a topic, what I want you to
do is start your text with a question. A
question holds the conclusion in
suspension. Something I actually run
with my academic and professional
writing class is that I have I literally
make them say this out loud in class. I
have them write down the question that
their essay is trying to answer, and
then literally in class, I have them say
out loud,
"Hmm, I don't know. What evidence would
I need in order to answer this
question?" And if you think you
understand this point that I'm making,
you probably don't. Because if you're
anything like my students, that you
know, I've lectured on this idea again
and again and again, and I'll go through
the whole semester railing about this
point that you do not start an essay
with a topic or an idea, you start it
with a question. And they say, "Ah, yes,
okay, I understand very well." And then
just to test them, I'll say, you know,
"Okay, we're going to write we're going
to practice writing an essay on the
board. And let's let's write an essay."
And I'll come up with a topic like, "Oh,
what's better, online education or
offline education?" And then I'll have
them stand up and go to opposite sides
of the room. So I'll say, "If you think
online education is better, go to this
side of the room. If you think offline
education is better, go to that side of
the room." And they all comply, and
they're all standing there. And then
I'll say, "Busted. How can you know? How
can you have an How can you have an
opinion? How can you have an answer to
that question if you haven't written
about it in the first place? Sit down,
you all fail."
>> [laughter]
>> I don't fail them, but I could. I feel
like I should, you know, I feel like
this If this was Squid Game, this would
be one of those like elimination rounds.
But the purpose of this activity is to
really hit home the idea that the
question is your filter. The question is
your filter. So like there's all this
evidence in the world, there are all
these quotes and things that you could
draw on in your own lived experience
that you could just throw into your
essay at will. But when you begin your
essay with a question, it becomes a way
of evaluating that evidence. And so you
look at the question, which is like
which is better, online education or
offline education, and rather than
standing up and going to opposite sides
of the room, making your choice, you
look at the question and you repeat
after me. And you say, "Hmm, I don't
know.
What evidence would I need in order to
answer that question?"
Right? If you begin your essay there,
now you have a filter. The question is
your filter for the evidence. Now you
can look out into the world of all this
data, all these experiences, all these
quotes you've read, everything, and you
know what to draw on. So without a
question, then you're basically drowning
in information with no principle about,
you know, how to choose what's
important. Beginning your text with a
question allows you to hold your
conclusion or your own ideas in
suspension while you go about searching
for relevant evidence. And this
principle of beginning with a question
can be a real problem for fast thinkers
and divergent thinkers. Because for
them, answers are jumping into their
mind intuitively, and they go grasping
for those branches as they occur to
them. So sometimes in these classes or
with my clients, they have a difficult
time with me. It feels like I'm trying
to rein them in or suppress their
thought. But really what we're trying to
do here is adopt a principle. It's
called the inquiry method, in case
you're interested in learning more about
it. But it's essentially a principle for
arriving at the truth. It's like in the
scientific method. Like we know that
humans are corrupted by our own biases,
and so over on planet science, we
developed this method that allows us to
approximate the truth, to come closer to
the truth, so that we know that we're
not being clouded by our own judgment.
And the scientific method is great in
the material world, but it's not so
useful in the world of values. Like you
can't really design a science experiment
to say what the meaning of art is or
which politician we should vote for.
Right? Those are value judgments. And so
you need a method like the scientific
method to help you arrive at a
principled conclusion. And that's what
the inquiry method does. And so with
this method, we are beginning with a
question. That's step one. You You start
with a question, and the question is
your filter for evidence, which is step
two. Now evidence, if if you know a
little Latin, then you know that the
root of evidence comes from the same
word for vision. So evidence is
something that both like anybody can see
just by looking. It's It's like raw
data. It's something that we can all
agree on that doesn't have values baked
into it. It's not good nor bad. It's
just true. And so that's a useful second
step, but it's not enough to get us to
developing a valuable idea. Right? We're
trying to write valuably, we're trying
to come up with new ideas, and facts
alone can't help us do that. What we
need to do is explain those facts with
our own reasoning. So that's step three.
Evidence exists out there in the world,
reasons are values that exist within
your own thinking. And at this point, it
almost becomes mathematical because it's
like, you know, we have a question that
we're trying to answer. Okay, let me see
what I can do. So here's the evidence,
and then I add my reasoning to it, and
then it's just evidence plus reasoning
equals claim. Now claim is your own
original idea. And if somebody doesn't
agree with your claim, what part are
they going to disagree with? I was like,
"Okay, you don't like my idea. Which
part don't you agree with? Do you agree
about the evidence? Evidence is
evidence. It's right there. Look at it.
Did I describe it correctly? Okay, well,
here's my reasoning. Do you disagree
with that?" And it's like, "Ah, no,
that's pretty good." And this is where
writing becomes powerful because now
it's like your idea is mathematically
sound. It's grounded in evidence, your
reasoning is right there to be
interpreted, and the new idea is just
the output of those variables. All
right. Now I know there was a lot there.
So as an overview, what is this method?
How do you write valuably? Start with a
question. All right. Now read widely
about that question, trying to answer it
to yourself. And as you find relevant
evidence for this, start to explain that
evidence to yourself in your writing.
Now once you've synthesized all of this
evidence into a framework that makes
sense to you, now you can start it. Now
you can start refining the style at the
sentence level, at the paragraph level,
at the word choice level, going through
the whole text. This is what it means to
use your writing not just as a vehicle
to communicate your ideas, pre-formed
ideas, right? It's to use it to discover
what you believe. This method is
probably the most practical approach to
this whole meme that we see online where
you know, writing is thinking. Well,
this is what I mean by writing is
thinking. All right? If you start your
text off with a question and you ground
your inquiry in the evidence and just
follow that evidence wherever it leads,
this is what writing is thinking means.
But I promised you power, all right? So,
how does this make you powerful? Well, I
think that if you follow this kind of a
writing process, then the payoff is not
stylistic. You know, I haven't been
sitting here talking about grammar and
word choice. What we've been talking
about is the method that you bring to
your non-fiction writing. And to be
honest, everybody wants to develop their
own style, especially in the age of AI
when all of our voices are starting to
blend together in this kind of
enthusiastic din, you know, this voice
that we get from AI. So, everybody wants
to develop their own writing style. And
let me tell you, your style does emerge
from this process. Like,
style is not reducible to the sum of its
parts. You know, you you can't exactly
describe the writing style of your
favorite writer. Take Hemingway, Cormac
McCarthy, David Foster Wallace, any of
these very stylistic writers. You can't
explain that style with recourse to the
mechanics alone. All right?
I think the way to understand writing
style is to think about the writer's
interaction with
their own inquiry, which sounds, you
know, kind of academic or whatever, but
really, I mean, if you're writing
valuably, then as I said before, you are
thinking thoughts that have not been
thought before. And so, you're
struggling with something. You you have
some new idea that has not been
articulated yet. And so, you're kind of
grasping at it. You're saying, "Oh, it's
a little bit like this. It's a little
bit like that." And then you've got this
mess on the page and now you start
refining it. And as a byproduct of of of
that struggle with the truth, a kind of
style that we can describe retroactively
by, you know, recourse to grammar and
word choice, that emerges. But it wasn't
pre-planned by the writer by thinking,
"Ooh, I'm going to use this fancy
uh sentence structure or whatever it
might be." Like, nobody's actually
thinking about that. All the stylistic
writers, you pick your favorite writer,
I think if you like them, it was because
they were dealing with something that
spoke to you. All right? So, and that's
the reason that the style works is
because they found something true
and they articulated it in a way that
resonated with you.
So, the point here about writing well is
not aesthetic. I'm not talking about
style. But I can promise that if you do
take this approach to your writing,
style will emerge as a happy byproduct.
But a better product for your writing is
power because if you're writing this
way, then you are you're kind of sending
your text out into the world. I almost
think about the text as like a third
party. There's you, there's your reader,
and there's this text that when you're
done with it, goes out into the world
and if it's written well, which has
nothing to do with style or mechanics or
anything like that, but if you're
writing well, which we have defined in
this video as writing valuably, then you
are kind of sending your text out into
the world to do something. Now, that
might be to persuade customers to buy
your product, it might be to overturn a
commonly held assumption, it might just
be to gain status with people whom you
respect and want to be respected by.
Whatever it is, your text is doing work
in the world. And the common thread here
is that you're using your writing to
affect change. And so, what's your
definition of power? What's your
definition of authority? My definition
is the ability to affect change and to
increase the likelihood that other
people will comply with your request.
Well, that's exactly what we've
described with valuable writing. You are
sending your text out into the world and
if it works, if you've written valuably,
then it does what you intended it to do.
So, there's no meaningful difference
between being authoritative and being
articulate. If you can articulate your
ideas, articulate your argument,
articulate your vision for the way that
things should be and you your text is
effective, then you are by that
definition authoritative. Writing is a
way to develop the skills that give you
real-world power. And so, even if nobody
reads today's essay, you have practiced
the skills that will help you tomorrow
when you walk into a boardroom or a
sales pitch or any of the other places
in your life where you might want to
wield that power. And I spoke a moment
ago about finding your voice or your own
writing style. And that is quite
important in this stage of AI because
honestly, everybody's voice is just
blending together in this homogeneous
kind of hygienic slop. And for that
reason, I've been thinking a lot about
writing style lately and you know, what
it means. Everybody talks about writing
style, but what actually is it? And what
do I do to develop my own? And I'm going
to be releasing a longer video on that
later on, so you can stay tuned for
that. But in the meantime, I what I've
been kind of coming to as I'm kind of
sketching out these ideas is writing
style is not exactly something that we
can describe at the level of word choice
and grammar. A better way to think about
it is to think of it as an integrity,
right? An integration between what you
think and what you say or write about.
When those two things are in line, when
you have a clear vision of what you
think is true by dint of your own
inquiry, you've arrived at truths that
that you truly see in the world and as
you articulate those truths, the words
that you grasp in order to share them
will form your own writing style. So,
writing style is not something you can
plan for. It's something that emerges
organically from this process. But at
this point, I've got to come clean
because the title and the thumbnail of
this video was actually designed to call
out a certain meme that floats around
here on writing YouTube. I'm never
beating the clickbait charges. This idea
that writers should just write about
whatever they're interested in and not
not even think about readers and write
even if nobody reads it or write as
though nobody's going to read it.
Honestly, I think this is a really bad
export from the world of fiction. Cuz
over on planet fiction, like, yeah,
maybe you should just write about
whatever you're interested in. Readers
be damned. But this meme has infected
the world of non-fiction writing and the
result is basically a whole ecosystem of
substacks that everybody writes and
nobody reads. If you've ever wondered
why nobody's reading your substack or
why a substack is so bad, this is it.
It's because all these people think that
they can just write about whatever it is
they're interested in and people will
just line up and willingly trade their
attention or even their money in order
to read it. This is not the way that
readers work. And I think the reason
that this piece of writing advice to
ignore readers is so popular and why my
message, which is to obsess over
readers, is not quite so popular, is
because it sounds like my path is the
path to audience capture. It sounds like
a cheap kind of degraded form of writing
where you're just a slave to reader
interests and you're not actually using
the full potential of writing to express
yourself and and and use it to do your
own thinking. This is why I'm always
stressing that there are two phases of
writing. And this video has been
focusing squarely on the first function
of writing, which is to use the writing
to do your own thinking. So, in phase
one, we're just thinking about the
writer and your own thinking. And in
phase two, we start to position your
ideas as the solution to problems that
readers care about. But it's true that
many writers who blend these two
functions together become paralyzed. And
that's why that earlier advice of ignore
readers is helpful to a certain extent.
But not only does thinking about readers
too soon in the process lead to writer's
block, but it can also corrupt your own
thinking. Right? If you let the reader's
concerns creep in while you're still
using your writing to do your thinking,
while you're trying to solve problems,
answer questions, examine evidence,
develop reasoning, we're going to turn
into these little social monkeys that we
are and our opinions are going to start
to be influenced by the people who have
now crept into the writer's room. If you
skip phase two where we think about
readers, then basically you're writing
for substack. Right? You're writing for
yourself. Nobody's going to read this
crap. But if you skip phase one, then
you are in the world of audience
capture. You're not generating anything
new, you're not generating anything
valuable, you're just giving the readers
what they want. And that's one kind of
writing, but you know,
it's not the kind of writing that I'm
interested in. Because this process with
both of these together are really
important. And whenever you subordinate
your own thinking to the opinions of
others, like go back to university.
Maybe you wrote a paper in such a way
that you were just trying to impress the
professor, right? You were just throwing
back their opinions at them.
It's very similar to the thing that many
people do when they're writing for a
specific audience, right? They're just
giving the audience the opinions that
they want. And by the way, all of the
writing teachers, and you know who they
are, who are telling you to ignore
readers and just write for yourself,
that's exactly what they're doing. They
haven't thought deeply about this
problem. They're just telling people
what they want to hear. Those people are
stuck in phase two. They're only
thinking about their audience, and
they're not actually thinking about a
problem. And the reason that this
audience-focused writing alone is so
corrupting is that it actually like
How do I put this? The thinking that you
do through writing, it actually becomes
part of you. It becomes part of your
cognitive structure, right? So you sit
down with a problem, and then you start
writing about it, and you start sharing
your ideas online, and those arguments
become a part of your character, right?
They become a part of the cognitive
structure, like the map or the framework
that you use to understand and interpret
the world. And your perceptions, in
turn, start to affect your behavior, and
your behaviors amount to your character,
and your character is your destiny. This
stuff is important, folks. So when you
start letting audience concerns, whether
your audience is a professor or readers
or whoever is reading your nonfiction,
when you start to let their opinions
influence your own idea generation, you
give up something truly vital about
yourself. All right, so language and
thought, at the end of the day, are
inseparable. You use language to do your
thinking, and as your thinking is, so
your language becomes. And this is what
gives your writing its value. It's not
the content that you produce. You might
write one essay today, which says X, and
then 3 years from now discover that you
actually don't believe that anymore.
That's fine. The value of your writing
was not in generating X or not X. The
value is the product at the end, which
is an articulate mind. So to learn how
to execute this two-phase writing
process step by step, you need to watch
this video next because it's going to
show you my expert writing process from
start to finish. So be sure to go check
it out.